Rihanna is worth $1.7 billion but the
majority of that money is not from music
it's from this and it's because of her
companies and so today I'm going to
analyze Rihanna's flre company Savage
xvy and my name is Alex rosi I invest in
companies I own acquisition. comom which
is a portfolio that makes unreasonable
amounts of money so be very very
impressed and at the very end I'm going
to be wearing all of this and so there's
five things that her companies
specifically Savage xvy does different
that I think any business owner can
model independent of whether or not
you're celebrity and if you watch
nothing else about this video make sure
to stay for the breakdown of her actual
membership offer she has like nine
different bonuses that she figured out
how to combine to make what would
otherwise not be a recurring product
into a reoccurring purchase that I
thought was really clever that I think
every business owner who sells stuff
even on any kind of subscription can use
so helping me out today will be my
lovely assistant Savage and Fenty and
let's pull up Rihanna's website okay so
here we are so Rihanna looks great this
is awesome and she's obviously selling
tons of product through the site but the
real question is how could she go from
zero to global distribution overnight
when she has no experience in
manufacturing no experience in brick and
mortar distribution and arguably
probably not that much experience even
in online shopping and so she did five
things that I want to dial in on so the
first thing she did was she partnered
for her deficiencies right and so she
has three cord deficiencies around this
business so the first one is going to be
distribution but I mean physical
distribution
she already has the media distribution
she already has the brand so she has the
eyeballs but how does she get the stuff
how does she get the stuff into people's
hands right the second is how do we
create the stuff how do we actually do
the manufacturing and then thirdly the
internet sales side is also a completely
different game from making music or you
know social media or even to a degree
design cuz I would argue that she
probably has a much stronger hand in the
design of the products which we'll get
to in a minute the first is that she
partnered with someone with an existing
distribution base lvmh and so if you
don't know what lvmh is lvmh uh is the
holding company of Bernard Arno who's
one of the top whatever 15 wealthiest
people in the world he's a centa
billionaire so if you haven't heard of
lvmh you've certainly heard of their
companies like Christian Dior Louis vuon
javoni Hennessy and Tiffany and Co and
they and they own a ton more beyond that
so the first thing she did was she
partnered for her deficiency now what
does lvmh bring to the table that she
could not otherwise have done on her own
now to be clear I'm not saying that
Rihanna doesn't have the ability to do
this it's just that she'd have to learn
a ton of skills that's probably not
quarter what she's really good at right
and so what things did lvmh bring to the
table so first and foremost they have
distribution so as much as she has the
media distribution that's a u there you
go maybe I can spell uh she has the
media distribution she can get the
eyeball she can get the attention she
has the brand Association which we will
talk about but if people want to buy
from her the vast majority of people
still buy lingerie in person and so even
though she has an online store where she
can drive people too they have physical
retail experience finding locations
building them out and basically helping
people build a retail model when she has
no retail experience the second thing
that they could help her on is
manufacturing right it's one thing to uh
you know make a a product to do some
Drop Shipping you know connect with some
little manufacturer the thing that
happens is the bigger you get the more
difficult supply chain becomes and the
more you need to have Partners who can
handle that kind of scale and volume and
here's the hard part day one right like
it's more common for you to sometimes
you partner with someone and they kind
of grow with you with their business as
your business grows but she's a super
mega A-list celebrity day one and so she
has access to almost like a global
audience day one and so she needs
someone with global fracturing and
global distribution day one and so just
put some numbers on this they have 118
factories globally and over 6,000 retail
stores so they have the experience so
zooming back out if you're a business
owner you're like okay what I mean
that's great for Rihanna what can I do
with this well number one is
distribution is one of those key things
that you can make Partnerships for that
Mak sense right like for example when I
uh invested in school I brought media
distribution right I had a lot of people
who wanted to to start businesses or had
businesses and wanted to build
communities online and so that was
something that I brought to the table
and so building distribution either
retail physical stores that is something
that that that's an asset it makes
something very valuable that you can
bring to a partnership for example again
when we had uh gym launch which was the
company that I started and sold we had a
distribution base of brick andmar gyms
and so when I started Prestige Labs
which was our supplement company I could
sell through that BR brick-and mortar
distribution base day one which is why
that company within the first month that
it's $1.7 million in sales in the first
month of really being in business and so
I I I bring that up to say that like
there are few things more valuable than
building distribution and so the third
one to tie this off is that they had
retail and
online sales experience right so they
they know how to build out the online
presence for all all the brands they
have under lvmh and they are probably
have teams upon teams of Specialists who
know how to run direct response ads who
know run branding campaigns that have PR
Specialists that can go and get her in
the right places at the right times all
of that stuff and so the big takeaway
for me and potentially you and this is
something that took me too long to learn
is that I think in the earlier part of
my career I wanted to learn everything
and I think that's very valuable but at
some point I believe that businesses are
limited by the collective brain power so
these are my little brains there we go
that are inside of an organization and
so if you're the only brain in the
organization because you have taught
everything you know to every other
person then it means that a business is
limited on one person's Lifetime and I
don't care how smart you are I mean if
you're Elon then you you know
congratulations you're an alien and and
have have beat everyone but for us mere
mortals we usually need to get other
people in their lifetime of learning and
put it all together so that overall we
can create a bigger Enterprise and the
best people in the
world don't do it for free and to give
you some scale here her laundry brand
alone did over $100 million in sales now
it's like how do we know what numbers
they're not super public about the
numbers and so but I think big picture
we can just say they make lots of money
what can we learn so number two is she
picked a good market now if you've read
the book $100 million offers I talk
about this before I even get into the
offer because your Market is more
important than anything else to give you
an extreme example if you were selling
toilet paper during covid you didn't
need to have an amazing offer if you
just had toilet paper you had what a
starving crowd right on the flip side if
you were trying to sell marketing
services and you're the best marketing
services in the world you're trying to
sell it to newspapers that are paper
newspapers those things are going down
no matter what right and so the first
thing that's going to be the biggest
lever on the success of the business is
who you actually serve to now the vast
majority of markets are neither of those
extremes they're not dying every day 25%
compounded inally in the wrong direction
or absolute Supply demand uh discrepancy
between the entire world trying to buy
toilet paper right most markets I would
just consider our normal markets now
what she did that was unique and so I'll
put it in here I'll pull this up from
the book is that there are four
components to a market that I like is
are they in pain do they have the
purchasing power are they easy to Target
and are they growing and so let's run
through the market that Rihanna selected
for her Avatar through this framework so
first and foremost were they in pain the
answer is yes and she actually followed
a rule that I really love when it comes
to product is that you want to have
lived with the pain of what you're
solving typically for a long period of
time now Rihanna is a uh uh she comes
from mixed ethnicity she has mixed
parents she has a very diverse
background and I think as a result of
that she also has a very diverse
audience and so one of the issues that
she found is that lingerie and
undergarments uh the nude colors were
not actually matching the vast majority
of skin tones so they had a hand they
had one nude but it didn't match
basically anyone and so she had a novel
idea which is number one is that she
offered 40 different shades of nude
underwear and so to quote her she said
there needs to be something for a dark
skinned girl there needs to be something
for a really pale girl and there needs
to be something in between right and so
that became the foundation of Savage X
fenty's entire business model and so
this then laded up to their overall
brand approach which is aligned with
Rihanna which was about inclusivity and
body positivity now part of that is
because this was a unique carve out from
the traditional uh industry standards
not to say that those are right wrong
it's just they were different right and
the other piece of this is that her
personally we've seen her kind of weight
Journey over time and so there's been
like thicker Rihanna and then there's
been thinner Rihanna and so in either of
some situations and obviously there's
people who are you know like I like like
Rihanna I like the skinny Rihanna
whatever the point is is that she has
gone through this experience she
resonates with the pain and her audience
knows that it's authentic when she tries
to solve that problem and so the second
thing that you want is purchasing power
now she had a very difficult decision to
make here right lvmh is a luxury brand
so this is a this is a company that's
known for selling bags for 5,000$ 10,000
$50,000 and sometimes they don't even
put the price on their sites because
it's so expensive and they ship out one
or two products two physical locations
which just to keep the scarcity so high
now meanwhile let's pull up our site
let's see if we can make sure that we
don't get banned from YouTube for uh for
softcore um look at the prices on these
These are super reasonable prices $5 for
g strings uh I mean actually I'm not
really a purchaser of G-strings but I
imagine that's not super expensive $25
12 for 2 for30 you know uh $5
accessories $10 bras $15 Sports Styles
$20 Lounge Styles $3 underwear right so
there's there's a lot of very affordable
stuff on her site and so for that what
she saw for the purchasing power for
very large audience was she just made it
affordable right and I think that was a
good brand move for her given her uh
upringing where she came from and kind
of like I think it was on brand it was
was the right move for her so first off
did she have pain yes and she lived with
that pain and she knew her audience did
too so she made the 40 colors next is
did she make it price so that the vast
majority of audience could buy it yes
her audience was everyone so she had to
make it affordable for everyone now the
next thing is was it easy to find now
this is one of the big things that she
brought to the table with her
distribution she was able to overnight
have the world find out about this brand
which is an advantage that most people
don't have and so she just she just did
a casual overnight 20year career to
build her brand so yeah it was overnight
naturally but she was able to easily
find the audience because she already
had them within her community and then
finally is this a growing market right
and so this is a company that is serving
an audience of people that's very
diverse they have posit body positivity
at least in the US people are getting
more of a weight every year and so
there's lots of people who feel
disenfranchised with the beauty industry
now there's a little bit of pendum swing
back there fine but buy and L L I think
that uh we can just look at the
projected value of her Market segment
and it's growing at a 5% kager right
which is basically compounded annual
growth rate and so not like she has a
lot of Market to go after and the market
itself is growing because she's a smart
businesswoman lingerie is maybe an80
billion market right at least in 2025 or
projected to be but active wear is just
under 600 billion all right and that has
a
23% annual ized growth rate compounded
all right so like this thing so at 23.5%
just to give you context that's doubling
every 4ish years all right like very
fast so like that means that if you
stayed in the same exact percentage of
the market that you have that means that
your company would double automatically
in that same period of time and so this
shows the advantage of having a Tailwind
versus a headwind like just keeping up
with the growth of the marketplace your
business doubles not a bad gig and so
for her boom she checks off the having a
growing market and so when we're picking
what industries we're going to go in
what adars we're going to serve it's
like cool let's make sure that we're
going after a clear pain Point that's
not being served do they have the
ability to pay for what we have can we
find them easily and are they likely to
continue to get bigger or smaller over
time when you ever have a kind of a
significant Innovation then you're going
to have people who follow right and I'll
give you a completely different example
uh Sarah Blakeley recently just launched
sneaks which is basically like high
heels that are sneakers and so her whole
thing has been how do I exploit
industries that have not made Comfort a
standard but are still in Beauty there's
going to be a large increase in these
high heel sneakers because women want to
be comfortable but also want the inches
and right now it's underserved and so
finding that pain and this is also again
like Sarah like just like Rihanna a pain
that she had lived with for years so the
third big thing that she did
exceptionally well was her brand now
you're like okay well what is what does
that mean with regards to this well she
is a mom she's had the change in weight
she has different body types and
different skin color kind of like
herself she's kind of mixed and so
because of that it made sense for her to
kind of do this brand now big picture
what I want to highlight here is why
would someone care about buying her
stuff versus what they already are
currently purchasing so she has this
massive audience of people that have
positive Affinity towards her positive
sentiment they like her songs they like
her lifestyle they identify with her
she's aspirational so if you've got two
bras that you're looking at right two
products and one of them is just from a
brand that you have no real Affinity
towards and the other is one where you
have this you're a fan of the person and
their and their price the same and the
quality is the same which one you going
to go with you're going to switch from
the one that you have no real Affinity
towards to the one that you do and so
she capitalized on that and so one
what's happening in a lot of a lot of
markets is that there are a lot of old
corporate brands that don't have
personel or have lacked personality
lacked Champions and so they've made
room for people to come in with a large
audience and who have stronger Affinity
to then create their own brands with
equivalent products uh in terms of
quality and design and upset the market
really quickly like you're seeing this
with Mr Beast and his chocolate bars
versus Hershey and I'll say let me give
you an example of a brand that's doing
this really well in my opinion Nike has
been able to stay iconic because they
actually leverage personal Brands better
than almost anyone else else and so it's
like well who's like if LeBron wanted to
start his own you know line it's like he
could but he just went straight to Nike
because if you want to compete with Nike
you're not just competing with Nike
you're competing with LeBron you're
competing with tiger for the the the
peak of his career you're competing with
you know huge teams I should probably
name more people that are associated
with Nike but all the greats many of
them have signed with Nike so it's like
you're not just competing with Nike
you're competing with all of their
legacies so Rihanna came up with this
this this bra that because she is a
mother and she wanted to make it easier
for nursing she wanted to have a bra
that helped her do that and so she made
a bra that did that and that bra she
made cheaper with a membership which
I'll talk about in a second but I think
the the underlying thought process here
is what can I do to make my product
faster for people easier for people or
more risk-free right and so these are
the the vectors of value creation right
and I talk about this in the offers book
at length it's probably one of the Core
Concepts within the book which I refer
to as the value equation which is the
dream outcome for them is that they want
to look sexy they want to feel confident
and maybe even relate maybe just a
fraction of how Rihanna feels they're
like she's cool she's amazing she's
Savage she's ferocious right I want to
feel like a baddie like her right and
then perceive likelihood of achievement
well you know what this actually fits me
it's actually my skin color this
decreases the risk around feeling dumb
feeling stupid when you put something on
and it's way too small or whatever right
and then time delay and effort and
sacrifice these are the things like how
do we make it easier so she made the
clasp easier and then uh she made them
more comfortable and then time delay
that's going to be more on the logistics
of shipping for this type of product
compared to maybe a service or something
like that and I'm going to talk about
how she hammered the value equation in
her membership model which she did a
number of unique things that I think a
lot of people could copy uh who are
watching this right now badir Riri uh
made her launch campaign and she
followed the clear textbook whisper
tease shout method and so she did a
whisper Campaign which was where she had
this kind of mysterious post right where
she had Savage xvy which was at that
time a mysterious account that she
followed it was the only thing she
followed and then overnight it got all
of this press because it was the only
thing she followed and it got all of
these followers virtually overnight like
177,000 followers in 24 hours with zero
content on the page think about what
what the whisper phase is right so it
call outs it's like an ad the co the key
phase here is curiosity right and so
this is keep the product itself
mysterious and hint at how big of a deal
it is but keep wiers short and bonus
points if you can show behind the scenes
now this then transitions into where
she's going for tease right so this is
where she then teases the upcoming
launch and she starts to fuel excitement
so people are starting to guess what is
this about now I think people had a
decent idea of what this what this
launch was going to be when she made the
te's right and so now people like the
anticipation begins to build and then
finally she transitions to the shout
phase which is basically giving people
the call to action yes it's live go buy
it now Savage X venty and she made it
available to her you know hundreds of
millions of of followers across all
platforms and I want to I want to talk
about something else that she did really
really well that I think a lot of us
business owners can model so one of the
things that Rihanna does exceptionally
well is she makes organic content right
and one of the key Parts is that she
makes her organic content contextual to
the platform so if you look here one of
the steps in making content that I have
inside of the book 100 million doll
leads right is that like this is you
know the the Old Linkedin Facebook
Instagram Tinder meme is that you can't
walk into a party I think Gary has a
great analogy you can't walk into a
party uh dressed in a tuxedo when you're
going to a club like it looks weird it's
out of place even though that tux
there's nothing wrong you look like
James Bond you look great it might be
out of place there now nowadays maybe
you'd be you know people would think it
looks really cool because I think it
would look kind of cool but you get the
idea right now she has uh a huge
following on Instagram huge following on
Tik Tok huge following on YouTube and
she makes the the content uh platform
specific and so there's very little
crossover between her Instagram content
her Tik Tok content her YouTube content
and her Tik Tok content YouTube and
Instagram and so she makes it platform
specific so she's very clever marketer
uh because she understands how the
platforms work and makes platform native
content and so here's more or less how
she breaks down on Instagram she does a
lot more high-fi stuff it's a lot more
aesthetic and so she'll do more
image-based stuff uh and she'll share
photos and you know models kind of
showcasing the lingerie now the only
behind the scenes material is probably
going to just be her stories all right
now Tik Tok is short short form videos
right and so there she's showcasing
products a little bit more um and she
has kind of hops on more trending sounds
and challenges uh and she's a lot more
collaborations with other creators and
because of Tik Tok shop it's easier for
her to have direct purchases right on
platform and then finally with YouTube
she's using more long form strategy she
so more try on hauls reviews promotes
her VIP membership which I'll talk about
in a second which I think is one of the
more clever things that she's done here
that I think a lot of businesses will
copy that you can too and so if your
cous all of this is branding all right
so with the exception of her making you
know direct ass letting people know
about the products that they can buy if
you just demonstrate the use of the
product if you demonstrate expertise if
you're in in a in a B2B or Services
business demonstration in a lot of ways
makes the association between you and uh
the positive sentiment that you want and
if you do that over and over again that
is what can take a high information
buyer somebody who needs a lot of
information before making decision which
is the vast majority of the marketplace
and then convert them into a customer
now number four the next thing she did
is she doubled down on Affiliates really
hard and I'm a huge fan of Affiliates uh
Allen my software company was built uh
entirely off of Affiliates Prestige Labs
was built off of a distribution base of
Affiliates of gym owners and so I'm a
huge advocate for Affiliates school is
65% uh affiliate traffic in terms of the
the percentage of the people who are on
school it's people from school who refer
other people to school right and so I'm
a huge huge advocate of this because
fundamentally Affiliates compound right
and they become these permanent nodes of
distribution for for you and so
obviously there's basically two levels
of Leverage that she was able to achieve
with this business first she was able to
leverage lvmh's retail distribution base
so that's the physical presence and then
layered on top of that she was able to
Leverage The aggregated Following of
many mega stars and what I think is
really unique about her affiliate
strategy is that you'll notice the
different look and feel of the
Affiliates I'll name them in a second
but like they represent different Beauty
ideals and so I think they were very
deliberate about who they chose so they
have people like the hadit sister gigg
and Bella Hadid they had Emily radch
Kowski I don't know how to say her name
but like very pretty lady but different
look they had Norman right again
different look lizo different body type
right Vanessa hudgin Cindy Crawford Demi
Moore and so lots of different looking
feels uh to attract a wider audience and
I think the common theme between all of
those is that they're considered
beautiful this is something that's
actually taking me a long time to learn
is that the Affiliates that you choose
have a huge influence and the reason and
I wrote this on the same page is a huge
influence on your brand it's a bir
directional relationship your brand
influences who's attracted to the brand
who wants to affiliate it and then those
Affiliates then reinforce the brand
itself of what are we about right what
are the associations people make with
our products and services and the things
they no like can trust all right she
followed the affiliate Playbook says
chapter inside of $100 million leads uh
to a so she found her ideal Affiliates
we just covered that now she made them
an offer now some of them is sponsor
ship some of them they get a SP
sponsorship and a percentage of Revenue
I would imagine that for the vast
majority of these types of deals they're
probably almost all just cash
sponsorships that they they make a
certain amount of post every year where
they're repping it and they're wearing
it and I think at this level I would
hope the vast majority of them it was on
brand for them as personal influencers
to make the association with Rihanna and
lvmh because lvmh has an amazing brand
too right um now obviously the
qualification they were already
Superstars uh we already covered how to
pay them get them to advertise that what
posting Cadence what things we want them
to wear right and so we have to think
about the value equation also for
Affiliates and I think this is one of
the most misunderstood part people think
they like oh I'm going to have an
affiliate program people just
automatically promote my stuff that just
basically never happens Affiliates
basically become another tier of
customer for you and you have to make an
offer so good they feel stupid saying no
just like you would for a customer and
so it's like how do I make it easier for
them so she sent them banners links uh
promotional materials so that it kind of
made it turn key for them so they didn't
have to you know take a lot of time to
to think about how they're going to
promote it and she could actually make
sure that their promotions were still on
brand and so to reinforce her Affiliates
positions as Premiere right in terms of
aspirational uh Savage xvent has a
fashion show that actually won an Emmy
that was on Amazon Prime and she invited
some of those Mega influencers to come
and join her to kind of rep it and so
this is brand a creative it's brand it's
brand additive to them so this is like
the perfect brand deal is one where both
part parties benefit from one another
and both Brands go stronger and have
more positive sentiment across a wider
distribution base than they did prior to
the deal because then there's zero cost
to the deal there's added Financial
value but there's also increased
Goodwill and distribution right like
that's those are the good types of deals
and fundamentally I think that's what
she was able to achieve so I'm going to
flash up some stats so Instagram
actually did a breakdown of this
campaign of how they were advertising
across uh social media and rather than
read you all these stats I'm going to
give you the the bottom line which is
that most direct response marketers it
takes everybody a different amount of
time to figure this
out but let's say this is the world of
potential buyers that you have well
about this many of them are ready to buy
today so this is the classic if you've
never heard this sta before it's 97% of
people are not ready to buy today and 3%
are right and so most direct response
marketers are all
fighting making better and better offers
to this tiny little dot but the clever
marketers who understand the longer game
is that this 97% you move along the
Continuum to hear through brand
awareness through brand education and
positive associations and so there's no
mistake that they did a lot of topop
funnel awareness a lot of associations a
lot of narrative a lot of aesthetic
storytelling pairing associations that
they deemed quality to their demographic
graphic so that when they did make an
offer to them they had moved them along
this Continuum into their now much
larger bucket that everyone else has a
3% bucket they're competing for and
maybe they're at a 15% bucket that's
five times big that looks like a three
there you that's a five um and so
fundamentally this is how Brands always
beat businesses that are purely direct
response you look at the biggest
companies in the world they're not like
they're not they're not Arbitrage
businesses they're not like I can buy a
click for a penny and I can and I can
sell it for two the thing is is that
brand advertising outperforms direct
response advertising every time as long
as you know what you're doing caveat on
a long enough time rizon and so in a in
in 30 days direct response will probably
be branding but on a year branding will
smash it and that's where you get those
20x 50x sometimes 100x Returns on
advertising dollars it happens when you
when you grow the pie and then no one
else can compete against you because all
of this extra that we grew with the
brand awareness is only extra for you
and everyone else is still competing for
this little Dot and you don't even need
to advertise that little dot because
you've got this massive pie right here
that you grew organically with Goodwill
with positive sentiment by the way the
reason I make these videos this is all
branding the whole point here is that
hopefully you can learn some nugget that
you can apply to your business and then
as a result make more money and
Associate that making more money with me
and she did this this growing of the pie
overnight over 20 years right of having
more like Platinum hits than almost any
any musician today um and maintaining a
very kind of cool
badir uh brand I ranked these in order
of what I would deem important St you're
like how could distribution from lvmh
for partnership be more important well
if she didn't have them she wouldn't
have a business right she wouldn't be
able to manufacture products she
wouldn't be able to keep up with the
demand she wouldn't have the brick-and
mortar distribution that she has she
wouldn't even have the necessarily the
brand Association of of Premium luxury
goods all of those things were massively
beneficial right the second thing is
that she picked the right Market if she
had picked the wrong Market to begin
with for example I think if she had gone
luxury I think that would have been
really bad I think people would have
been like she's being ridiculous she's
so greedy she's which which is hilarious
uh that she's so greedy really she just
made more money doing it this way just
because she was being smart it would
have just been a bad move given her
brand now for example like we do huge
you know very big deals in terms of what
we do so it makes sense for anything
that I would eventually sell to be
expensive right it makes sense so second
like I said if you don't have a good
Market that you're going after it's
going to fall in flat ears if she had
done a big luxury move and gone like
$5,000 $10,000 St I think it would have
been a disaster right so she picked the
right market and she was clever about
the fact that not only did she go after
Ling Ray she also went into into
Athletics stuff right well this is
loungewear but the idea is that those
are growing at disproportionate faster
than population growth and GDP growth
she's going into growing markets she's
going into drinking she wouldn't have
sold anything to begin with third then
when you have the growing Market you
have the distribution brand allows you
to capitalize on it that allows you to
get people to switch from what they're
currently buying to your thing because
they have brand Affinity because of the
20 years of Goodwill that she's built up
from the music that people associate
with going out from having fun from just
relaxing from in their drives all of
that positive sentiment built up over
years then gets monetized flipped when
she starts presenting real products now
when she has that then it's like how do
I get leverage on that because if she
had just done that she would have made
plenty of money but how do I get more
leverage fourth she brings in the
Affiliates now she gets even more
leverage on the distribution in terms of
media by also getting more inclusion
because of different skin types color
types Beauty Aesthetics Beauty ideals so
she can capture a wider percentage of
the marketplace and then finally number
five now we talk about the offer all
right and so this is in order of
importance all right so she had what I
would consider a grand slam membership
offer because she could have had just a
generic offer and I think it probably
would have done fine but she did a
couple unique things that I think are
really worth uh dialing in on now there
were some technical components that
required her to do this and um she did
get a little bit of dings from uh from
Regulators but I will I will talk about
that briefly so let's look at the core
components of her membership and so
there's kind of Three core components
here one is so remember the grand slim
offer right so you have you want
something that's going to be uh easy you
want it to be be fast you want it to be
low risk all right and then you want it
to have the dream outcome all right and
so each of these elements of value are
actually woven into this membership so
it's not just a normal membership where
you just uh you know like a like a a box
subscription right you you pay 50 bucks
a month and you get a box of stuff every
month that I think would have not done
very well and probably would have had a
tremendous amount of churn now the
amount of members they have on this the
sources are kind of varied my guess is
she's probably got over a million people
on this thing making it easy easy and
fast to join so they do it right at
checkout that's not necessarily unique
but what I think they did make that
unique is that anybody who buys
basically buys into not only a discount
Club so you save money immediately by
joining the club so thing one so let's
just let's outline these things so she
gives a
discount for being the membership is
this unique not really there's plenty of
discount memberships that exist now
number two getting a little bit more
unique she also includes VIP
benefits that are media related okay so
she provides behind the scenes fashion
shows access exclusive content that she
has inside of an app her VIP extra app
um where she shows this stuff so people
feel more connected to the movement that
she's trying to build with Savage X
fenny really clever so this is a a
brilliant kind of combination of the
physical products world and the digital
Community World which is something that
I'm I'm all in on when it comes to like
school right school one of the big
reasons I made the investment is because
there's so many businesses that benefit
from it right like if you're an
e-commerce business you should have a
community for all of your customers to
be in cuz guess what happens there they
buy more often they refer more friends
they give you feedback back on the
products so that you have more insight
and Intel so that you know what your
next product should be or how to make
2.0 versions of it to make them even
better all of that stuff and the nice
thing is you can offer it for free right
and the crazy thing is is you'd pay for
the Intel that you get from a community
but here you actually you're you're
going to just convert more people into
it so it's awesome all right now here's
one of the most clever things she did um
I I I I think I think it was I think
this is the the best part of of this
membership is it's skippable all right
so what does that mean so remember I
said you have to have easy fast low risk
now the low risk has multiple components
to this so one risk is that I don't get
something that I want right that's a big
risk um and that has two components one
is paying for something that I don't
want or that there's just nothing
available that I don't want uh she
handles the first one with having the
different colors the different designs
and so that one's kind of handled but in
terms of okay what's in my box that I
get every month well what they do is
they actually personalize the
recommendations per person person
monthly all right so these are all
personalized based on your shopping
Behavior so once you make your first
purchase and you join the the community
you join the membership they then tailor
the recommendations for the box for you
every month based on those past
purchases all right so this makes it
more likely lower risk that you're going
to get what you actually want but let's
say that you see this box of stuff and
you're like well I don't want any of
this stuff well she made it skippable
and so think about it like this for the
first four days of every month they say
hey here's the stuff that you can buy
here's the stuff that's that's catered
to you and you can say you know what I
don't want it this month and it just
skips the billing and so you actually
just get basically the opportunity to
get stuff at a cheaper price and you
don't have to even pay to do it you just
stay in it and so it's almost like being
locked into a free in someways dis
membership and then when you choose to
buy something and if you assume you
would be buying stuff anyways which is
what this kind of capitalizes on then
the months that you want to buy
something you can and with the credit
and so this is here's e
it's based on a credit system so when
you actually buy the subscription
doesn't necessarily send you something
in the Box they give you a credit that
you can then redeem and pick and choose
the pieces that you want which also
means that let's say you uh get a $60
credit which is the price point that she
has if you want to buy a $75 thing you
just pay 15 bucks a checkout and worst
case scenario let's say that uh you
don't want to buy anything that month
well next month you're going to have 60
plus 60 so you have $120 that you can
spend and so in some ways it almost acts
as lay way for some people to almost be
like a savings program where they can
save up for a special occasion and then
Splurge with the discount that's already
locked in and so I think this
combination of skippable and
personalized plus the credit I think
this is a really really compelling
combination that has led to the success
of the membership offer these are the
big ones but let's talk about other risk
things well one they have a 90day fit uh
guarantee so that gives so again risk it
decreases risk even further right so
you're like okay well I want to pay less
and have more time to return stuff that
makes sense they also get Early Access
all right so that's closer to the
approximated dream outcome right if
we're talking about the four values
right so like okay now I get to see this
stuff earlier you also get a free annual
gift so that's more bonuses right during
your birthday month right when people
are at the height of their emotional
peak of like wanting to feel special
they make them feel special and they
associate that feeling with the brand
brilliant move all right on top of that
they have free shipping on all $59 Plus
ERS meaning anybody who redeems their
credit gets free shipping on whatever
they buy right so this encourages more
people to of course use the membership
and they get up to 25% off so it's
pretty significant discounts and that's
year round right and they get 15%
discounts on skin which is a different
company overall that's when you start
being able to cross pollinate by
different different companies which is
just a brilliant move on her part so
look at all these benefits this is what
you might consider a bonus stack if you
will um just done in a physical product
space and on top of that if if you but
wait there's more right she also has a
free underwear pick or bra after every
fifth billing now why do you think they
did it after every fifth
billing because they probably know where
their average turn is and so they
probably have delayed a bonus past the
average Turn Point to give someone
immediate reward for staying
longer and so then they summarize this
on one place which makes it a super
Grand Slam offer which is why I wanted
to make this video because the the
amount of people are like man I I read
the offers book and I just don't know
how I can apply to an e-commerce
business
this is how you apply to an e-commerce
business right and of course they make
cancelling easy uh so you can go there
you can call them um and uh you can
cancel obviously online and so the core
membership offer she presents is $59.95
a month and it's credit-based and so now
let's lock into what are the specific
extra bonuses that she does to make this
a grand slam offer not just a
traditional membership so if you're
wondering okay well beyond the first
purchase how is she getting these
personalizations
a brilliant lead magnet so if you don't
know what a lead magnet is I covered in
the book $100 million leads and so if
you want to get more traffic to convert
give them something very valuable for
free now the point here is that let's
say that you just said hey go buy My
Thing versus hey try a free thing and
then once they get value from the free
thing then asking the people got the
value to then buy the thing you will get
way more people to ultimately buy and so
this is kind of a little visual that I
have to explain the difference like you
might have a 100 people that you talk to
you get one sale versus low trust
turning them into a high trust audience
and then getting three times the sales
right which is super common all right
and so there's different types of lead
magnets now for hers she's using type
number one which is revealing a problem
and so when you reveal a problem it's
doing it through personalization so you
can watch as we walk through this and so
she's able to personalize
recommendations not only based on what
they buy but she can also change the
shopping experience based on what people
already say they want or likee and so at
the end of this personalization
obviously they have to to tie it to a
contact so after you go through this so
you have sunk cost bias right you have
consistency and commitment bias so
you've already gone through this and
you're like oh shoot I might as well
make an account and she still gives you
a cookie for doing it which is that she
gives you a discount code as soon as you
sign up for it and so you can do this in
any business so for example for
acquisition. for business owners uh we
have a scaling road map so it it gives
you a personalized road map of whatever
stage of scaling you're at between 0 and
500 employees and we broke it into 10
stages across eight functions so it's
like what do you need to do for sales
when you're going from 50 to 99
employees what do you need to do for
marketing what do you need to do for
customer success what do you need to do
for product what do you need do for it
what do you need for recruiting what do
you need to finance what do you need for
HR right for each of these functions
what's the problem and what's the
solution at each stage right and it's
very different going from five to nine
employees uh versus going from you know
50 to 100 right so you want to be as
personalized in your deliveries as
possible and so if you want to check our
version out you can go to acis.com
roadmap that being said the point of
this type of lead magn which I'm
obviously a fan of is revealing the
problem then you then have your delivery
mechanism for what that lead magic is
going to be now for her she uses
information as the thing that she's
basically doing so the for her the lead
magnet then turns into physical
basically informs uh the physical
products that she's going to offer right
that's fundamentally the issue now I
guess you could have a discount I don't
normally consider uh discounts as a lead
magnet I kind of see that as a component
of an offer um but yeah fundamentally
that's how it works and guys don't be
afraid of asking for more look at this
this this is Step eight of eight right
like if you need more information to
make something more valuable for someone
ask for it right like a lot of people
have this fear of like oh my conversion
rate is going to go down it's like yeah
but conversion rate of whom right like
of people who really want to buy the
thing like they probably will finish it
now to be clear there's good friction
and bad friction like you don't want to
make the the user experience clunky but
if fundamentally you need the
information so that you can give them
more value then ask for it like we ask
for more information about the business
so that we can make a personalized road
map for you which we have some
automation cool stuff in the background
that delivers the stuff that you need at
your particular stage in business and so
there's more than like hey just your
name and phone number right it's
personalized so one of the really clever
things that credit-based memberships
have is that they basically function
like gift cards and I'm a huge fan of
gift cards for a variety of reasons the
biggest one being it's basically getting
a interest free loan from your customers
all right and so whenever someone you
know signs up for a gift card they
basically front you money and you
haven't done anything yet right so from
a cash flow cycle it's a it's the most
accelerated cash flow possible they pay
you and you don't have to do anything
right and so the idea is one you have
faster cash flow which is good second
some percentage of people are not going
to necessarily redeem it and so that
becomes pure profit right because the
way that hers is written it's not
redeemable for cash in any way all right
now I think one of the the the unique
components of her membership offer
really smart because lingerie in of
itself right not as recurring of a
purchase like if you were if I were to
say hey name me a membership type you
probably the first thing that came to
mind probably wasn't going to be lingre
it pro if anything that just when I
think lre I think special occasion right
which by its very nature is going to be
intermittent not recurring on a regular
basis right otherwise it wouldn't be a
special occasion just be an everyday
occasion right and so it's like how do
you get people to consistently buy from
you well the discount is a huge part
because they figured that over the year
they're going to buy number one number
two they can choose to not purchase
anything the whole year and so they can
just choose to execute their credit only
on the months they do have special
occasions but at least it keeps it top
of mind and I would imagine that many
women her target audience um like
shopping and it's almost like window
shopping done digitally where they say
hey here's a bunch of stuff that we
think you might like and some people
just enjoy window shopping I mean it's a
it's a it's a it's something that women
do on a regular basis or people do on a
regular basis in real life and they do
the same thing online people browse and
they don't buy anything because they
still get some DOP mean or whatever it
is that re forces them from looking next
thing that she's really gone all in on
with this membership is that it's she
she almost makes it hard to not buy the
membership um and so you can look here
at her purchase page so first off the
button says member add to bag it doesn't
say buy it doesn't say guest check out
it says member add to bag and you can
see the the breakdown too where she has
kind of like a a double price drop right
so you've got guest purchase which is
almost gray out right you can even see
they they they changed the pixel so it's
a little bit um it's like good better
best right and so the worst here is you
know guest is
$12.95 right then member is $9.95 but
for you because you're brand new and
we're I'm I'm obviously not a a g string
uh painting collector um maybe I am who
never know my my other my other life um
but it's uh it's $518 so you see this
tremendous price drop so 60% off and if
someone's like well shoot I'd rather do
that and then when you find out oh you
can just apply that today and never have
to pay again because you skip
functionally every other purchase that
becomes a very attractive offer but you
have to cancel in a month right well you
could cancel whenever you want but you
probably only be reminded to cancel in a
month but at that point they'll present
you new stuff and so if you have a
membership offer I think making that
your primary offer and then basically
downselling the premium is one way of
doing it that obviously has worked very
well for her and I will mention this
just because I think it's an obvious one
having thirdparty financing is is is
very uh you'll just make more money so
if you don't have that integrated to
your site especially if you're doing
physical products uh you're typically
losing somewhere in the neighborhood of
30% of your sales and so to summarize my
rating and critique for this business I
rate this a baddy business out of 10 and
if you want me to break down or critique
another business and run through the
models that we teach acquisition. put it
below and I'll put it in one in my in my
lineup for next businesses